oh thank you
hi how are you how's Jays come so far
cool cool so my name is Max Emiliano I
know it's a long name in fact maybe you
know me as Maximilian all third man okay
thanks to responsive and CSS max is fine
I can go by max so I'm a mobile web
developer I have been doing web
development since that browser
okay so 1995 roughly so I'm traveling a
lot for conferences training and
consulting I'm from Argentina from
Buenos Aires I have also a couple of
books the last two are on web
performance and I'm not here to talk
about myself but how the app ecosystem
is broken and probably you know this for
example this is my phone this morning so
it's trying to update 231 apps ok so I
encourage you to do the same thing
disable automatic updates and see what
happens
so also probably you have here about
news in the past few weeks and month for
example problems with apps that are
currently sending a lot of data to
different servers they are selling your
data while you are sleeping not just on
iOS also on Android and again because
I'm traveling a lot I flew here through
New York because I had a flight
cancellation I saw that in Manhattan
that's a Penn Station in minta and in
downtown Manhattan download the app for
the train station so do we need an app
for the train station also if you go to
the store ok it's 50 megabytes ok for
the train station app reviews are pretty
bad ok it's not just that up ok so this
is a common scenario we see this every
day
Umbra you are thinking well we are
talking about pwace right so pwace
should be the answer for a lot of these
apps ok that's why today I am starting a
new Twitter
pound it should be a PWA okay that's for
real so it should be PWA so you can be
the first follower by the way the idea
is to show a lot of apps that are out
there that should be based on the web
platform there is no need for an app so
oppressive web apps don't ask me for a
definition we know it's not so clear how
many of you have created pwace let's see
around 30 plus percent how many of you
are working on the web most of you right
so it's basically the same so why 70
percent of you are not saying that
you're creating pwace so I offered this
article okay in net magazine a few
months ago and I really like this as a
definition okay the the graphic design
the graphic idea that PWA is the current
DNA of the web okay so it's it's
basically the web so just for for the
seventy percent of you if you have never
heard about this just it's a web app
with service workers and with let's say
an optional layer that have to do with
distribution how users will install or
use the app because installation is not
mandatory the user has to use the app
the web app from the browser so right
now today 81 percent of your users are
able to install the PWA from the
browsers they're actually using to
access your web sites okay it's a lot on
mobile it's 92 ok
on desktop is 69 and of course these
data these numbers are getting higher
every day
so this is the support of mobile on
Android it works on every browser when
you are in a website that is a PWA you
can actually install it from out to home
screen that's the J's conf PWA and then
you have an app that app looks like any
other app on Android okay you have seen
this we hope before probably so that's
that's I think it's pretty cool it looks
like any other app on Android the same
happens on iOS you can go to tinder
you're not in there no one
so tinder is a PWA so you can go to on
your iPhone and
the share sheet I'll to the home screen
and it will create an icon I probably I
think you know but that's not the PWA
it's just a shortcut to the website but
if you open that icon now you have a
standalone fullscreen experience that
from an OS perspective it looks like any
other app on the iPhone so it's
basically a PWA
and then you have kayo s and G oh those
are feature phones are a couple of
million users for example I have this
Nokia here with me feature phones
non-touch there are supporting pwace but
it's not just on mobile on desktop you
can also go and install for example
three bago you can also tell tinder by
the way so and you have a add a desktop
window with the app ok and that works on
Windows Chromebooks Windows 7 8 and 10
Mac OS and Linux and of course you can
open more pwace at the same time so we
have the platform we just need to create
really really good experiences and today
let's say that I can say that maybe half
of the PWS out there are offering a good
experience but the other half are still
far away for offering for offering like
a competition for the native apps and so
we will try to see why and what we can
do today to improve that experience so
about the apps cycle ok
so because we're creating apps not just
websites that will appear in the browser
so when you open a PWA
so the app loads like any other web
content that's not support no surprise
but what happens when the user goes to
the background such as pressing the home
screen well you have this ability change
event and there you can pause the game
or an animation you can stop a timer ok
because you're not in the foreground
anymore but a couple of seconds later
mostly on mobile devices such as Android
the app might be suspended and there is
a new freeze event
meaning that Europe will be still in
memory for a while but you won't be
executed any code so if you want to save
the state or do something this is your
last dinner
okay the freeze event and then you go
back to the app and if you're lucky
enough the app is still in memory and
now resume will be executed and also
BCBG change again let's say that when
you close let's say close the PWA you
were using an intensive operation apps
such as recording a video watching
Netflix movie or using a 3d game when
you go back your app was discarded from
memory so in this case the PWA will
start from scratch like a normal load
but there is now a new boolean value
that you can query this card that will
give you true okay in that case and
there you have the opportunity to load
again the state the previous state that
you saved before okay so you need to
start doing this so what about iOS iOS
is not following exactly this rule in
fact I did a research on the lifecycle
of an iOS PWA and it looks like this
okay so anyway the the important part
here is that I'm here in the PWA on iOS
I you can zoom in you can scroll you can
click you can type on a form so that's
the current state when you get out of
the PWA okay your your app is currently
frozen so when you go back you can see
the recycle splash so it's starting from
scratch but basically Apple WebKit is
restoring the state but if you kill the
app it also restores the state so there
is no way to actually restart the app
from a scratch you can buy a new iPhone
ok if you want or at least you can
restart the phone that's a problem ok
because if you have an invalid state
there is no way to get out of that
invalid estate so it's a good idea
on iOS at least to provide a reload
action within your UI
at least until Apple changes this also
you can provide a full navigation like a
back back button we do have Chester's
here like swipe from the L gesture to go
back but also it's a good idea to add
visual UI for this
so what about the resources service
worker is the one that is currently
storing and saving and serving those
files so the problem is that there are
situations where you can find this you
open an app this is the uber bwa on
desktop and uber in this case chrome is
saying hey I don't have the files I say
how is that possible well because the
browser can will eat the files if there
is storage pressure so no more space on
that device unless your request for
persistent storage so this is something
you need to do is please Lee right it's
a promise API so you just ask for
persistent storage so your files will be
there now let's move to another topic
this is progressive experience so far we
have been creating one app for all so
your gradient app Bonita is react
angular view wherever remember but it's
just one app for all but we have a lot
of devices we have desktop devices we
have phones high-end phones low-end
phones feature phones that might
actually be run in Europe also we have
different connections with bath with our
latencies sushi 3G 4G no 4G I'm here
with a 4G device on roaming and it looks
like a slow 3G okay and also maybe you
have a Samsung S 10 with the best LTE
plus plus super ultra but you have four
percent of battery I need something from
your web app but I don't want you to
load okay
those four megabytes of JavaScript so
what I'm saying that maybe we need to
copy something from YouTube you to have
a mental model for users like YouTube is
trying to guess the best possible
experience for that user and it's
picking one quality but the user can go
and change that why can't we do the same
on our PWA so there are not sleepy eyes
today to know about the context such as
the network information API performance
observers device memory API so you can
gather information about that current
scenario
you can make some decisions also there
is a reporting API available today
it's an HTTP header where you can send
an endpoint or a URL and then the
browser will send you for that
particular user with real user metrics
information reports about performance
issues on that particular device on that
particular network so then you can make
decisions to keep a consistent
experience okay because we want to have
a consistent experience such as changing
the serviceworker cache policy based on
this ESS our service our render
Brousseau clients are render you can
switch based on the scenario reducing
the amount of loaded data and many other
tricks that you can apply so we want to
offer a good experience for every user
we are creating pwace for a real
operating system so we need some kind of
platform integration so we need to do
something else
compared with a normal website so for
example web authentication is it's
really a good example of how you can
improve this quickly today for example
100 flowers it's a PWA
where you can actually log in pretty
quickly with your current session on
Android I don't I didn't have an account
on that website before but with one
click and I mean okay this is coming on
Safari as well web share you are
creating an app that it's a standalone
so full screen there is no browser UI so
how can I get out of my my PWA how can I
get my content out of my PWA
well we can share the content with a
very simple API available right now on
iOS Android and some desktop operating
system for example I'm here on Twitter
on iOS Twitter PWA
ok not the in the native app and you can
just share from there I opens the native
share dialog so I think that's pretty
cool and also we have a version that is
web shared target API I can take a
picture from my Photos app and I can
share that picture into the Twitter PWI
okay directly that's the second version
of the API that is currently in cannery
okay and talking about Android for those
of you in Android we have something
known as web apk how many of you have
care about web apk whew
I can see no hands at all so that works
automatically on chrome and Android
when you install a bit of a leeway from
chrome on Android on the in the cloud
the Play Store is creating an APK and
application Android package okay the
native Android packet format and it's
installing that silently in the device
which means for example the J's confit
evaluates actually an Android app I can
go to settings and seats and Android up
it even says that it was installed from
the Play Store which is false
okay so that's because it's signed by
the Play Store and that creates a really
cool first-class experience for your
Android users and the same happens on
Samsung if you're on a Samsung device
and you're using the Samsung into the
browser in this case it's a web APK
signed by Samsung Apps so this is
interesting because now you're creating
Android native apps from an Android
operating system point of view now
talking about dekstop so today on
desktop you can do multi window that's
Google Drive on desktop it's a bit of a
leeway you can actually open new windows
so it's a multi window world you can say
well on the web it's multi tab okay but
you need to know what you're going to do
with this now the user can have several
apps you can use the serviceworker for
example and the message API to make some
kind of control and future looks really
promising so let me show you a gnarly
mock on how to have application mode on
pwace might look like later maybe this
year I don't know so this is from the
last Google i/o where you can see it's
your app with several tabs inside
so on Dexter we have a lot of new
challenges on the web
going back to us as our last platform to
talk about let me tell you this so if
you google pwace on iOS the first the
second and the third articles there are
my articles okay and the snippet you see
there it's also coming from one of my
articles there is no documentation at
all from Apple or from the WebKit team
they are supporting partially or totally
or buggy the technologies that there is
no documentation okay so you need to be
careful test a lot and add some metadata
that is required for an Iowa anyway so
let me tell you one thing only Apple
shame on you right so because this is a
problem that we have as a community so
installation experience so we are
creating apps okay so we wanna create
apps so we need to improve how users
will install our up first because most
users will never know that there is an
Add to Home screen or an InStyle menu in
the three little dots menu in the
browser so we mentioned that we have
this web app service worker and
distribution rings here I did this on
purpose I didn't said web app manifest
on the red ring because I don't think
it's the only one
whether manifest is one of the key
aspects of a BW a of course it's the one
that will give you on desktop reason
that installed button directly in the
omnibox of the URL bar in edge and
chrome it's also giving you the mini
info bar on Android and on other
browsers it will give you several
batches when you are a PWA you are
passing the PWA criteria but that I
don't think this is the only important
part on on a PWA you must provide your
own install button within your UI within
your menu whenever you feel it's a
moment to offer the user installation
you can act
surely add your own in Salvatore so it's
simple but we are okay so you need to
listen for a new event before installed
prom when the browser things that you
are passing a PW criteria it will fire
that event so you need to basically
prevent default first just to avoid the
browser to show its own banner and then
you wanna save that argument that you
receive for later usage and then when
the user clicks on that button you will
just call prompt okay so that's roughly
how it works and then you can create
your own in L button that will trigger
the native dialog on desktop and on
Android devices so apart from what
manifests are already mentioned you need
to add iOS metadata and something that
it's not completely new but for most web
developers it's something like new an
app launcher so an app launcher it's an
80 package for one OS that will trigger
a bit of a leeway I'm not talking about
a hybrid like we see in Cordoba Apache
Cordova or PhoneGap I'm talking about a
launcher that opens the browser and a
special fullscreen panel own mode okay
so we are not packaging our files our
CSS HTML and JavaScript files we are not
packaging those flashes launching the
PWA and the serviceworker will take care
of loading the files so for windows we
can create an AP px
okay that's the format available and
then you can go to the Microsoft Store
for Kai OS so again for this Nokia
device you also can create a cash app
generator there are some tools available
free tools that will help you in in the
creation of this so again you still have
your web app you still have your service
workers we are talking about the the
Outer Ring okay
just that you need to do something else
not just the web manifest for these
these operating systems
bro you're thinking well what about Play
Store
what about Android let me give you one
example one example that I mentioned
before one
and the flowers and e-commerce ID from
us we can buy flowers they created a
really good PWA there were even
mentioned in last Google i/o keynote
they also used to have or have a native
Android app that was ok reviews from the
native and web was kind of ok well Play
Store today
you go to trending then the fifth one
it's a hundred Flowers ok and you can
actually go there and install the app
from the Play Store
okay well that app is basically a PWA ok
if the PWA so now they have replaced
their native up with a PWA this is now
possible so you can elect new apps as
anyway so you can if you have on your
company crappy Android native app you in
package ID and then upload a new version
and all your users will receive now the
PWA version and from now on you don't
need to upload any more updates because
you just change the files on your server
you don't need to package new new apks
so this is thanks to trusted web
activities there is something new
available on android with chrome maybe
it's going to appear with other browsers
as well so far it's only on chrome that
will let you compile around Android
Apple you need to use Android studio ok
it's one line of code that you need to
set that is basically your URL you need
to certain you need to serve that you
are the owner of that PWA of the atom of
that URL and when you do that you set
the icon the URL and you go to the Play
Store so you can actually today publish
pwace it in the Play Store okay so what
about iOS can we do something for iOS
probably thinking no well let me tell
you I found something not exactly what
you're expecting anyway but I found a
way using a tool on ask Apple
configurator
where you can actually set web clips for
fullscreen that full screen thing there
that is basically a PWA so this creates
a mobile config file that you can serve
on safari on your website or you can
send by email and if the user accepts
that configuration file it would uh no
more icons that you are setting in that
file this is for enterprise distribution
okay it's not my friend users but for
enterprise distribution this is one way
that you have today to distribute your
pwace one tool that is really cool and
interesting that you can use today to
create these packages because hey we are
web developers okay yeah and wrested is
there is kind of a tricky right to
understand Android studio and how it
works
pwe builder it's a free tool from
Microsoft that will let you create all
these packages even if you don't have a
serviceworker it will help you create in
the serviceworker if not if you already
have a PWA it will create the APK for
the Play Store the appx for Microsoft
Store and it will even create you a
version for the ios app store using in
that case the webview so it will be like
a hybrid for iOS for the app store so we
can distribute apps in the store
probably I think hey but we are the web
we shouldn't be in the store that's a
different discussion but from a business
point of view it's a good idea to be
there but we need to be careful because
not every app can be in the store for
example there is a PWA today that i'm
not sure if you have hear about that
icon how many of you know what that icon
is no all right have one here well that
is you porn okay so they have a bit of a
leeway and of course they cannot be in
the store okay so because the store has
some rules and you need to check those
rules it's not just for adult content
you cannot publish private apps up for
your employees for example you cannot
create app there is using paper or other
mechanisms to sell content so
you need to check those rules okay so
the modern pwh egypt okay we have seen
basic pw8 support that we need to add
then understand the lifecycle
progressive experience not the same up
for all the users then platform
integration we need to integrate with
every platform bugs hacks we need to do
that unfortunately then we need to
improve installation experience creating
your own install button and also
publishing in the store okay so this is
for me what you need to do today to
create really good pwace okay that's all
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]